dune is one of the most famous sci-fi
books ever the story of paul atreides
rise to power is widely read and been
made into movies and tv shows but this
book is not the whole story of dune
frank herbert wrote six dune books and
it's only in these sequels that the true
meaning of june is revealed the dune
sequel books get weird paul's son
transforms into a worm god and rules for
thousands of years duncan idaho gets
resurrected hundreds of times there's an
invasion by dominatrixes from space and
genetically modified cat people and
chairs made out of living dogs and each
book is full of secret plots and
abstract philosophical ideas it would
take many videos to fully explore these
books so first what's the basic story
what happens in frank herbert's six june
books
in book one house atreides takes over
the desert planet arrakis land of sand
worms and spice but they're attacked by
the hakonens and the emperor paul
atreides unlocks a powerful mind that
can see into the future he becomes a
religious leader to the native fremen
and falls in love with cheney he defeats
the hakonens and defeats emperor shirdam
and paul becomes emperor of the universe
so book one seems to be a classic story
of a hero fulfilling his destiny and
defeating evil
but in book two june messiah paul being
emperor is a disaster the fremen kill
billions of people in their holy war and
paul can't stop the violence his
religion is out of his control
a conspiracy of powerful people plot to
destroy paul led by gaius mahayam and by
paul's wife princess ireland with a
spacing guild navigator and a tlalaksu
face dancer and paul's own fremen high
priest these guys have an elaborate plan
to destroy paul using a cryptic dwarf
called bajaz who manipulates a
resurrected version of duncan idaho who
is now a mentat philosopher with robot
eyes
paul knows there's a plot against him
but he allows some of their plan to
happen anyway because he's afraid of
even worse possible futures happening
instead seeing the future is a curse a
trap that takes away paul's free will
paul gets blinded by a nuclear weapon so
he relies on his visions to see like neo
in the matrix iii
cheney dies giving birth to twins lato
the second and genema
paul wants to escape his grief and
politics and destiny so he walks into
the desert to die
so in june messiah polls rise as a
heroic leader turns out to have been a
terrible mistake he loses everything he
loves and gets billions of people killed
the message is that religious and
political leaders are dangerous blindly
following a messiah or a vision or plan
can lead to disaster
book three is children of dune paul's
sister alia rules the universe on behalf
of young lato and genema but alia's mind
gets possessed taken over by the memory
of the baron vladimir haarkonen
turns out that the baron was alia and
paul's grandfather and his personality
corrupts alia's mind and leads her
government into decline
it turns out that changing the
environment of a racket to have water
and plants is a disaster because without
desert there's no sand worms and no
spice and fremen desert culture starts
to die
paul turns out to be still alive as a
mysterious desert preacher he criticizes
the atreides religion and government but
ends up getting stabbed to death by his
own priests
when cecio carino the daughter of the
old emperor shaddam plots against the
atreides she tries to kill leto and
genema with laser tigers so lato fakes
his own death and gets super high in the
desert to unlock his mind and lato sees
a possible future that could save
humanity from extinction a plan called
the golden path
lato transforms his own body so he'll
become part sandworm and will rule the
universe for thousands of years
jessica deals with the carinos by
converting their heir to the bene jesuit
alia kills herself to kill the baron
within her and wormboy lato becomes
emperor plato's plan will apparently
save the human species but to be the
savior he has to give up his humanity
and become a monstrous tyrant dune
rejects the heroic messiah paul and
instead turns to a darker more
complicated leader
book four is god emperor of dune set
thousands of years after the previous
books lato rules the universe with an
iron fist his plan the golden path is to
oppress humanity for thousands of years
to teach the species to want freedom to
grow stronger and to think for ourselves
leto also breeds the atreides bloodline
to create siona atreides siona has a
special gene that makes her invisible to
people who can see the future so siona's
genes will free humanity from the
control of prescient people
lato falls in love with a woman called
hui
trapped in his monstrous worm body lato
is tormented by the loss of his humanity
his tragic self-sacrifice to save the
species
over the centuries lato resurrects
duncan idaho over and over and he allows
duncan and siona to rebel against him he
teaches duncan and siona so they grow
strong enough to eventually destroy him
in the end duncan and siona kill later
by using the blind obedience of nayla a
fanatic of lato's religion lato's dying
body rejuvenates the sandworms and spice
on arrakis and humanity is finally freed
from his control after millennia of
oppression humanity bursts out across
the universe in the scattering a mass
migration into space
humanity expands and evolves to save it
from stagnation and extinction just as
lato planned his golden path gives
humanity a universe of infinite
possibilities
book five heretics of dune is set
another thousand years in the future the
bene jesuit control much of the old
empire but a new threat comes from the
scattering the honoured matres are a
wild offshoot from the bene jesuit who
use sex to enslave people the beni
jesuit train a girl called shiana who
can control sandworms and they hope to
breed her with a new resurrected duncan
idaho and to use her as a religious
force to control people
but there's also a plot by the
talaylaksu a bunch of religious genetic
scientists who look like creepy grey
elves the tlailaxu secretly modified
this new duncan giving him special sex
powers that terrify the honored matres
bene jesuit leader teraza uses duncan to
lure the honored matres into destroying
the planet arrakis because by killing
the planet's sand worms they destroy the
remnants of emperor lato's consciousness
and end his influence on the universe
the benejezer at take a sand worm to
make spice on their own planet called
chapter house terraza is helped by miles
teg a legendary atreides mentat soldier
who sacrifices himself and dies on
arrakis
in book six chapter house dune the
honoured matres rampage across the
empire hunting to exterminate the bene
jesuit the beni jesuit go into hiding on
the planet chapter house under the
leadership of dawi o'drady an unusually
rebellious reverend mother who wants her
sisterhood to change and evolve to
survive this crisis
o'drady creates a young clone of miles
tegh who is her father and she trains a
captured honored matre mabella to be a
bene jesuit
mabella and duncan fall in love
teg leads an attack on the honoured
matres but the matres defeat tag with a
secret weapon and they kill a drady so
mebella infiltrates and takes over the
honored matres from within then she
merges the honored matres with the benny
jesuit assimilating them to create a new
stronger sisterhood mobella has changed
so duncan decides to leave her he and
shyanna steal a spaceship and escape the
sisterhood along with the last living
claelaksu master and a secret group of
jewish people and some sandworms and a
van gogh painting together they start a
new journey free in the infinite
universe
in the final chapter we see a mysterious
elderly couple called daniel and marty
these two are apparently advanced face
dancers from the scattering who escaped
the control of the tla laksu but daniel
and marty also seem to represent the
author frank herbert and his wife
beverly
as they work in their garden they break
the fourth wall a little chatting about
june's characters and the unfinished
plotlines like the tlaxu they admit that
the characters got away from them they
are now beyond the author's control
the book ends with a loving tribute to
bev who died the previous year and the
year after publication frank died
so frank never wrote a neat final
conclusion to the june series but this
open-ended last chapter fits the central
themes of june the characters get
freedom and self-determination not even
the author controls them anymore and
daniel and marty in their garden show
the simple human warmth that is the
emotional heart of dune
dune was never really about the plot as
much as it's about the ideas a
philosophy of the mind of thinking of
politics technology of how to live in a
chaotic universe so we're making a video
called the philosophy of june to explore
the themes and big ideas of the series
we're also going to cover the new game
of thrones tv show house of the dragon
which is based on a book called fire and
blood
fire and blood and the entire dune
series are available on audiobook you
can get any one of these for free right
now at audible.com asx sign up for a
premium plus trial membership and you
can choose an audiobook to keep even if
you cancel the trial you could get the
dune audio collection with readings and
commentary by frank herbert himself
membership also includes unlimited
access to thousands of audiobooks and
shows in the audible plus catalog sign
up at audible.com asx or text asx to 500
500
thanks for watching and thanks to the
patrons including j lee 60 micah prude
reuven dewenda hill1030 dylan elliott
and rilhonn cheers
you